yesterday you may have seen a video
about building an industrial scale Robo
collar I decided to take that video down
and destroy all the physical copies
because even though it's an obvious joke
it's not the right way to be using those
tools but the good news is that I recut
that video and it keeps the most
important part intact which is building
a scheduled task queue with firebase
cloud functions and make sure to leave a
comment on this video for the t-shirt
giveaway even if you left a comment on
the original and lastly I just want to
take a second to say thank you for
supporting the channel
20:19 has already exceeded my
expectations and the video ID list seems
to get longer and longer just don't
expect any Robo color tutorials anytime
soon
- call me ASAP as possible Thanks
Americans get at least 5 billion spam
robo calls per month and that number
gets bigger and bigger every year
personally I get at least 10 of those
calls per day and I finally just decided
if you can't beat them join them in
today's video we're going to not build a
robo caller music and a brand new cloud
function type from firebase but more
importantly we're going to build a task
runner that allows us to schedule any
back-end code to run at any time if
you're new here like and subscribe and
you can find the whole source code on
fire ship IO and leave a comment below
for a chance to win this one-of-a-kind
t-shirt next week so firebase released a
new function type a couple days ago it's
a pub sub function which allows you to
pass messages in between Google services
that is also integrated with Google
cloud scheduler this means you can run
any back-end code at a specific point in
time using a cron tab schedule this is
great if you know exactly when you want
to schedule a job in advance but I want
to push things a step further by
integrating firestore to create a
dynamic task runner that allows you to
schedule a job at any point in time that
allows you or your users to schedule
anything dynamically such as
notifications reminders or as we'll see
soon definitely not robocallers make
sure you have the latest version of
firebase tools installed version 6.7 or
version 2.3 of the firebase functions
module from there we can initialize a
new project by running firebase and it
functions I'll be using typescript and
you'll see why it's so valuable for a
project like this in a few minutes let's
start by taking a look at a basic
schedule pub/sub function in the index
TS i have a reference to the admin SDK
as well as firestore which we'll be
using later to create a scheduled
function we'll call functions pub sub
scheduled the scheduled method takes a
crontab schedule as its argument which
itself is just a string with five slots
that represent the minute hour day month
and weekday of the schedule in my code
here I have the minute set to 30 and the
hour to 5 so this will tick at 5:30 a.m.
every day but I wouldn't recommend
trying to memorize how cron schedules
work because there's this app called
cron tap guru that makes it easy to edit
and customize cron schedules from there
we just call on run that gives us access
to a callback function which can execute
background code on this schedule that's
easy enough but our schedule is static
so what if we want to change the
schedule or allow the user to schedule
something dynamically in this demo we
want to build a robo caller that can
scale up to millions of phone
calls per day and scheduled those calls
at different times throughout the day
for that we're going to build a dynamic
task runner and we'll start by modeling
the data with firestore we'll create a
task collection and each document will
represent a job that we want to run in
the background at a specific point in
time
the first field you'll see here is
worker which is just a string that
represents a JavaScript function that
lives somewhere in our back-end code the
worker handles all the business logic
and the firestore document is really
just a messenger to pass data to the
backend the next field is status this
will just tell us whether or not a task
has been completed or whether or not
it's scheduled or maybe a teardown
the next field is perform at which is a
time stamp that tells us when to execute
this task you'll want to make sure that
this is a firestore time stamp to ensure
it's consistent across all of your
clients then the fourth and final field
is options which is just a map that
allows us to pass any serialized data
into the back-end function so what we're
going for here is a generic system that
allows us to name a function and then
pass some data to that function and have
it run securely in the backend on a
specific schedule that can be
user-defined if you create this document
in the front-end that's how we get data
to the backend now we need to execute it
by defining a task runner this is simply
a scheduled function that runs every 60
seconds and checks to see if we have any
jobs that need to be executed this
function will be invoked about 45,000
times per month which is well within the
free tier on firebase if you're worried
about cost and you can even use this to
optimize cost because you can run
multiple jobs within a single function
invocation I'm gonna go ahead and create
a function called task render and I'm
going to increase the memory to two
gigabytes that part's completely
optional but if you're running a lot of
tasks you might want to just max out the
memory and then we'll call pub/sub
schedule and for the schedule we'll pass
all stars or wildcards this will have
the function tick every one minute and
that's actually the max level of
granularity that you can achieve with a
crontab schedule it's likely that we
want to run a lot of different jobs
concurrently so we'll do this inside of
an async function and then we'll want to
get the current time as represented by a
firestore timestamp we can use this to
query firestore for every job that has a
perform at timestamp in the past this is
the jobs that we want to run right now
and then we'll also make sure that each
task is scheduled because we don't want
to run a job that's already been
completed this will make it a composite
query so keep in mind you'll need an
index and firestore to run this query
the next thing we'll do is
this collection by calling a way to
query get and then we're going to make
sure that each job is a promise so I'm
creating an empty array here that will
be an array of promises that we can
execute concurrently from there I'll
loop over every document in the
collection and from each document I want
the worker function name as well as any
options that we need to pass into that
function we haven't defined the worker
functions yet but we'll do that in the
next step it's simply going to be an
object that has a series of functions on
it so we can call those functions based
on the objects property name now because
we're going to force each worker
function to return a promise we can run
them all concurrently and we can also
handle these success and error cases in
a way that's generic so we can handle it
the same way for every job that's in
queued no matter what it's business
logic is doing in this case we'll just
go ahead and update the underlying
document to a status of complete or if
it's an error we'll update it to a
status of error and lastly we'll go
ahead and push it to the jobs array and
the final thing we need to do from our
task Runner is just return promise dot
all with the jobs array so that's all it
takes to create a basic task runner with
this new pub sub function type and
firestore now it's time to define the
business logic for the task runner the
logic will be kept in this workers
object and I'm going to create an
interface for this object because it has
a specific signature that it needs to
follow the keys can be any value that's
the name of the function and then the
function itself has an options object
which we can use to pass in any dynamic
data to the function at runtime and that
corresponds to the options map on the
firestore document and lastly we want to
enforce that each worker function
returns a promise now we'll go ahead and
define the workers object and we'll give
it a key of hello world which is a
function that just returns a right to
the firestore database let's go ahead
and deploy our function and make sure
the task runner is working we'll go into
firestore to the task collection set the
worker to hello world then set the
status to scheduled and the time stamp
to sometime in the past after that we
just need to wait about a minute and
then we should see the status flip to
complete and then we should also see
this hello world document in the logs
collection in the original video this is
the point where we built the Robo caller
but I'm just going to go ahead and wrap
things up here the important takeaway is
that you now have a system that can
schedule any back-end code dynamically
some good use cases might be allowing
users to schedule push notifications
reminders or transactional email but
definitely not robocallers if this video
helped you please like and subscribe
and consider becoming a pro member at
fire ship IO to get access to even more
content thanks for watching and I will
talk to you soon
[Music]